salut et si je vous disais qu'un
japonais avaient combattu trente ans
après la fin de la guerre persuadé
qu'elle n'était pas terminée est ce que
vous croyez à ça c'est ce qui s'est
passé pour irun houda un soldat japonais
qui a continué la guerre pendant de
nombreuses années alors qu'elle avait
pourtant bel et bien cesser sa part est
complètement dingue pourtant c'est réel
comment n'at-il pas pu se rendre compte
de ça plutôt quel a été l'élément
déclencheur pour lui faire comprendre
qu'enfin la guerre avait vraiment pris
fin pour répondre à ces questions et
vous raconter son histoire surprenante
je serai aux côtés de louis san qui
parraine ce dixième épisode déjà dix
épisodes c'est incroyable merci à vous
tous d'avoir soutenu ce nouveau form of
grâces est bienvenue on va s'intéresser
au cas étonnant de ce japonais engagés
dans son combat jusqu'au bout et je suis
revenu en parler aujourd'hui avec pas
bien c'est parti bien dit et bienvenue
dans cabinet curieux
[Musique]
pour comprendre le contexte historique
il faut déjà savoir que le japon a lancé
sa conquête militaire dès 1931 en
touchant une dizaine de pays dont la
chine la thaïlande les philippines et
l'indochine française le japon est allé
jusqu'à bombarder par l'art bord aux
états unis en 1941 et c'est cet
événement spécifique qui a marqué son
entrée officielle dans la seconde guerre
mondiale
notre histoire commence en 1944 au japon
durant la seconde guerre mondiale à
cette époque les jeunes hommes sont
réquisitionnés en tant que soldat pour
aller combattre les américains c'est le
cas de l'inde entre un jeune homme
japonais de 20 ans heroes ou nuda qui
est enrôlé lui aussi afin de s'y
préparer il va mener un entraînement
intensif pour le former aux techniques
de la guérilla donc ce sera par exemple
des arts martiaux des opérations de
secrètes et même de la philosophie il
est ensuite envoyé sur l'île pardonnez
mon accent loup banque dans les
philippines en tant qu'officier commando
qu'ils auront l'audace d'un officier
très respectueux et très obéissants
envers son major yoshimi taniguchi ce
dernier va lui faire une promesse cela
peut prendre trois ans cela peut prendre
cinq ans mais quoi qu'il arrive nous
viendront te chercher une promesse forte
qui je voue la vous va transformer les
30 prochaines années deux kilos au onoda
mais concrètement très bien c'est quoi
sa mission à soldats concrètement sa
mission va être de surveiller ville de
détruire les installations portuaires et
aériennes pour empêcher toute invasion
des américains aux philippines mais en
février 1945
les soldats américains débarquent et
anéantissent le lieu irun houda va alors
se réfugier dans la forêt au plus
profond ou plus dense avec trois autres
soldats autant vous dire que les
conditions de vie vont être très
difficiles la dengue est un
environnement hostile où il est
difficile de trouver de la nourriture et
qu'elle le coup en construisant des
huttes en bambou en voulant de la
nourriture dans des fermes et puis tout
simplement en tuant des animaux coup de
théâtre le japon capitule en août 1945
le combat est terminé sauf pour ses
soldats parce que vous allez me dire en
même temps comment est ce qu il pouvait
le savoir eh bien pour les informer que
la guerre est bel et bien terminée il ya
un avion qui distribuent des tracts en
survolant lille le tract affirme
expressément que la guerre a pris fin le
15 août et qui peuvent sortir des
montagnes pourtant philo onoda n'y crois
pas c'est impensable pour lui que l'
empire puisse être vaincu d'ailleurs
c'est tout aussi impensable pour ses
coéquipiers pour eux il s'agit d'un
piège les tracts en question d'ailleurs
sont truffés d'erreurs donc ça ne va pas
rassurer le soldat non plus mais le
japon il va pas perdre espoir avec kg
noda et il va carrément envoyé des
membres de sa famille pour le rassurer
et lui dire que la guerre
et bien terminée mais comme on peut s'y
attendre eh bien il reste but et est
bordé il pense que tout ça c'est une
machination et c'est un piège immense il
va continuer de surveiller lille avec
ses coéquipiers jusqu'à parfois se
battre avec la population de l'île mais
après cinq ans ils sont tous fatigués et
un de ses coéquipiers essayé d'appliquer
les 22 ans plus tard en 1972 irun ou
d'acquitter enfin sa cambrousse avec son
coéquipier dans le but d'aller attaquer
les troupes philippines malheureusement
son coéquipier va périr dans un échange
de tirs et hérault où nous da se
retrouve seul livré à lui même en
parallèle le gouvernement japonais
pensent qu'il est mort parce qu'ils ont
lancée effectué des recherches qui n'ont
rien donné il reste introuvable mais
c'est sans compter l'intervention d'un
étudiant japonais l'agneau suzy qui se
rend sur l'île en 1974 avec une quête
pour le moins très étonnante étonnant
oui c'est le vôtre est bien mais a lieu
ce qui a pour objectif je cite de
trouver onoda un panda et l'épouvantable
hommes dépêche
si personne ne la trouvait jusque là et
que tout le monde le pense mort comment
un étudiant pourrait-il renverser le
destin est bien ringo tout simplement
avec de la persévérance cet étudiant
parvient à retrouver kg onoda mais ce
dernier encore une fois refuse de le
suivre et refuse de sortir il ne
rentrera pas chez lui et il attend
toujours et encore les renforts que
s'est-il passé ensuite comment ils
auront l'audace et ils raisonnent et
quel a été l'élément déclencheur qui a
permis enfin de libérer ce soldat et
bien justement l'élément déclencheur
c'est l'ex commandant de heroes ou nuda
nario sujet qui va essayer avec succès
de retrouver sa trace mission très
compliquée parce qu'il a quitté l'armée
et qu'il s'est reconverti en libraire au
fin fond du japon et c'est ce major
l'ex-commandant de heroes ou nuda qui va
se rendre sur place en 1974 soit 29 ans
après la fin de la guerre pour expliquer
haïr ou qu'elle est terminé et qu'il
faut déposer les armes on peut le voir
ici en train de quitter l'île et oui
promesses tenues entre kg onoda et le
commandant tenir jusqu'à ce que les
renforts arrivent le soldat il est pas
du tout goûté il dit avoir eu de la
chance de pouvoir se consacrer à son
devoir durant ces jeunes et dix grosses
années on peut voir à quel point
l'engagement pour lui c'était très très
important je cite ces mots je suis
devenu un officier j'ai reçu un ordre si
je n'avais pas pu le respecter j'aurais
eu honte il faut comprendre vraiment que
durant toutes ces années la seule chose
qu'il avait dans sa tête c'était
d'accomplir son devoir alors y'a pas non
plus que du positif c'est tout de même
assez difficile pour kg noda de
comprendre qu'il a tué des dizaines de
personnes sur l'île dans une guerre qui
faisait partie de son imaginaire et
pourtant il est accueilli comme un héros
par ses parents et par une foule en
délire complètement agité combattre pour
son pays pendant 30 ans a fait de lui
une véritable vedette mais pour lui
justement c'est une toute autre histoire
qui se joue et qui se déroule vous
doutez bien 29 ans après yves rouau noda
n'a pas retrouvé exactement le même
japon qui l'avait laissé en partant
combattre il avait l'image d'un pays
conquérant en triomphe rend tout cela
s'est effondré pour laisser place à un
empire vaincu un pays qui sait aussi
moderniser et développer en termes de
technologie et en terme de population en
bref un retour aux sources assez
déconcertant pour heroes ou nuda ce qui
l'a poussé d'ailleurs à s'installer au
brésil un peu plus tard pour devenir
éleveur de bétail
qu'est-il devenu justement après toutes
ces années louis après son accueil il a
reçu une pension militaire et il a
décidé de publier son autobiographie
sobrement ma guerre de trente ans sur
l'île aux banques puis totalement il
retourner au japon en 1984 avec sa
compagne où ils ont été un camp en fait
c'est un camp en pleine nature pour les
enfants pour leur apprendre des
techniques de survie je vous avoue qu'à
mon avis il est calé le fil renaudat et
pour la belle anecdote philo onoda et
retourner sur l'île de lubang en 1996 où
il a fait une donation de dix mille
dollars pour construire une école sur
place en 2010 il est nommé citoyen
d'honneur du japon et meurt quatre ans
plus tard à l'âge de 91 ans la question
c'est comment peut-on arriver à ce stade
là comment cet homme at il pu survivre
seul et a refusé de croire toutes les
personnes qui venaient vers lui et même
tuer des personnes pendant 30 ans et est
de la folie passagère de la paranoïa
même non il ne s'agit pas de folies il
était loin d'être le seul en fait
c'était surtout l'un des derniers ce qui
explique la quête de cet étudiant en
réalité étaient cent vingt-sept soldats
a continué à faire une guerre
n'existait plus entre 1947 et 1974 127
soldats continuent à faire une guerre
invisible
la chercheuse béatrice très folk
explique que ces soldats qu'on appellera
un petit peu plus tard les traînards
étaient avant tout des victimes de leur
entraînement deux soldats et deux marins
selon elle la marine impériale et
l'armée ont fait en sorte que jamais ses
soldats depuis ce faire une tentative de
reddition et que jamais il n'envisage la
moindre éventualité de retraite ou de
défaite ces gens d'ailleurs selon elle
toujours ont été un puissant rappel du
passé agressif du japon on constate un
fort dogmatisme chez ses soldats une
adhésion forte aux principes militaires
en général quelle que soit la formation
qu'ils aient reçu on ne peut que admirer
ce héros qui a tenu seul dans la jungle
autant de temps une histoire digne des
plus grands films et c'est d'ailleurs
son histoire qui a donné lieu à
l'écriture de honau daddy minuit dans la
jungle un film sorti en juillet 2021 est
présenté au festival de cannes
[Musique]
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
merci beaucoup à louis san d'avoir
participé à cet épisode si vous avez un
intérêt d'ailleurs pour le japon sa
culture sa gastronomie etc je vous
invite à faire un tour sur sa chaîne
étonnante où vous allez apprendre plein
de choses mais vraiment c'est très
intéressant que vous ne savez sûrement
pas sur ce fabuleux pays merci fabien
pour cette invitation merci beaucoup à
vous de vous regarder la vidéo jusqu'au
bout n'hésitez pas lâcher lousse bleus
je vous dis à la prochaine chose si vous
me connaissez pas je m'appelle fabien
olicard et pas par exemple julien
sauciflard loïc n'ont donc fabien
olicard et si vous êtes très curieux
sachez que j'ai un magazine c'est la
troisième année que je l' ai dit ça
magazine mensuel qui fait plus de 50
pages et qui s'appelle curieuse et c'est
que sur abonnement ce qui permet de
faire un prix pas chers et surtout que
l'abonnement il comprend les frais de
port où que vous soyez dans le monde et
ça évite aussi de générer des déchets
par exemple si on le mettait en kiosque
eh bien on sera obligé d'en fournir à
tous les kiosques qui seraient détruits
après donc c'est économique et c'est
écologique je vous mets le lien dans la
description ces curieuses point fr là
vous pouvez vous abonner encore pendant
quelques jours pour le prochain numéro
de mai puisque avril du coup il est déjà
imprimé le numéro 2 mais il va être très
intéressant vous avez le sommaire qui
apparaît à côté de moi et on aura
d'ailleurs un gros dossier sur les casse
têtes et sur l'un des principaux
distributeurs de casse têtes en france
hubert de l'insoluble qu'un vrai
passionné vous allez voir ça va être
très intéressant bref tout est dans la
description n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à activer la cloche pour voir les vidéos
de cette chaîne parce qu'on ne sait plus
quoi regarder un terrain entre ce qui
sort sur tik tok sur netflix sur machin
bon activer la clause ça fait plaisir
c'est le dixième épisode je le dis qu'à
la fin pour les très vrai d'entre vous
je fais un concours d'un d'une clé usb
collector avec les 10 premiers épisodes
de cabine et curieux sur mon instagram
il s'affiche ici voilà on aura que 10
dont 2 ou 3 2 je vais garder pour moi
donc n'a pas beaucoup à gagner si vous
voulez vous passer sur mon instagram
pour le merci encore d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo ça fait extrêmement plaisir
ici je vous en met deux autres l'épisode
8 et l'épisode 9 et le mois prochain
nous parlerons ensemble d'une
malédiction voilà à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]
tous